Trascrizione: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Revisore: TED Translators admin
È da 40 anni almeno
che il nostro ecosistema mediale sta mutando.
Dico 40 anni perché ricordiamo tutti che
la data di nascita di Internet è il 1969.
Siamo forse nella storia di internet
già in una terza fase della storia dei comunity network;
negli anni '70 e '80 il web
e adesso la fase del web 2.0.
Siamo ormai assolutamente abituati
all'idea della convergenza
che era un tema accademico fino a poco tempo fa,
cioè l'idea che sul medesimo canale distributivo
tutti i contenuti multimediali vengano distribuiti.
C'è una larghissima ricerca che comincia a parlare
di "nativi digitali".
Il nativo digitale a cui ho tagliato la testa per ragioni di privacy
è mio figlio, è un bimbo di 3 anni
che utilizza i libri di carta della Disney
nello stesso modo in cui utilizza l'iPad
e la mescolanza nella sua dieta mediatica quotidiana
di nuovo e vecchio è assolutamente naturale.
In questo contesto,
le biblioteche occupano uno spazio particolare.
A partire perlomeno dall'800, nella storia più antica,
le biblioteche pubbliche diventano il luogo operativo,
ma anche il simbolo dell'accesso universale
all'ecosistema dei media,
un ecosistema che nell'800 era molto più semplice,
molto più limitato di quanto accada oggi.
Oggi le biblioteche, e parlo soprattutto delle biblioteche pubbliche
rivolte a un pubblico larghissimo, non specialistico,
non al pubblico accademico, non al pubblico degli archivisti,
non al pubblico degli storici,
sono ancorate al sistema tradizionale dei media
e rischiano quindi una rapidissima obsolescenza.
Le salveremo da questa obsolescenza
solo aiutandole a entrare pienamente in una nuova fase
di cultura digitale.
Gli Stati Uniti e l'Europa sono due ecosistemi digitali diversi,
anche se noi possiamo distinguerli in termini di scala;
in realtà quello che sta accadendo negli ultimi anni,
articola uno scenario di divisione radicale.
Da un lato, grandi aziende
che sono pronte a competere su scala globale
con una nuova modalità di distribuzione dei contenuti:
Amazon, Google, Apple.
Dall'altra in Europa, nessuna impresa
che oggi sia in grado di competere, e neanche ci prova,
su una scala davvero globale.
Un continente di utilizzatori.
La situazione delle biblioteche
riflette esattamente questa realtà.
Quella mappa che vi faccio vedere,
e che ovviamente non possiamo leggere in dettaglio,
è la mappa di quanto, oggi,
siano distribuiti gli ebook nelle biblioteche americane.
E il totale di quella mappa ci dice che il 67%
delle biblioteche pubbliche americane
ha una collezione di ebook da offrire ai propri utenti.
Quell'altro diagrammino, difficilmente leggibile alla distanza a cui siete,
ci parla dell'impatto delle biblioteche pubbliche americane
ed è un'altra cosa che ci distingue da loro.
Negli Stati Uniti nel 2009,
69 cittadini su 100 sono entrati in una "public library".
In Italia erano 11,7. Un quinto.
Negli Stati Uniti la partecipazione
alle biblioteche pubbliche è maggiore
della base elettorale di fatto.
In che modo può avvenire il cambiamento delle biblioteche
e cosa è accaduto nelle biblioteche americane
e che cosa bisogna fare accadere nelle biblioteche italiane ed europee.
Quello che vedete è il bancone del prestito,
sembra quasi il banco del check-in di un aeroporto,
una grande ed eccezionale biblioteca pubblica,
quella della città in cui siamo.
Una biblioteca che presta circa
un milione di oggetti l'anno,
ma sono oggetti fisici.
Quello che dobbiamo fare, il processo che dobbiamo innescare,
è quello di trasferire queste transazioni in rete
e passare ad un modello di "digital lending".
Sulla base di questa analisi che vi ho riassunto brevemente
nasce nel 2009 medialibraryonline
che è allo stesso tempo un progetto imprenditoriale,
il progetto della mia impresa,
e un grande progetto cooperativo
che coinvolge direttamente le biblioteche pubbliche.
Siamo partiti con qualche centinaio di adesioni,
a distanza di due anni siamo a 2000 biblioteche in 10 regioni,
ma moltissime altre realtà stanno aderendo.
Che cos'è e cosa offre questo servizio?
Si riassume molto semplicemente.
Innanzitutto, accesso remoto ai contenuti per l'utente,
cioè la possibilità di accedere ai contenuti della biblioteca
attraverso un portale web,
24 ore su 24, 7 giorni alla settimana, 365 giorni l'anno.
È una piattaforma condivisa
che consente alle biblioteche di cooperare tra loro
ottimizzando in un modo incredibile i costi.
Questo è un punto
sul quale non posso entrare in dettaglio,
ma la sostanza della faccenda è che
una biblioteca di Aosta e una biblioteca siciliana
possono acquistare assieme dei contenuti
e nella pratica quotidiana, operativa
di gestione dei fondi bibliotecari
questo comporta e ha dei potenziali di risparmio straordinari.
Pensate, giusto per darvi un'idea,
che il costo nelle aree più efficienti del paese
di una transazione di prestito bibliotecario,
escluso il costo del contenuto stesso,
è tra 3 e 6 euro;
cioè ogni volta che una biblioteca efficiente in Italia
dà a prestito qualcosa
spende in costi complessivi di gestione del processo
tra 3 e 6 euro.
Se date alla mia impresa questi quattrini
noi possiamo regalare questo contenuto agli utenti.
La terza cosa è una grande collezione di contenuti digitali.
Vi dò una mappa di massima
di quello che oggi c'è qui dentro:
40 000 ebook, 1500 quotidiani da 80 paesi in 40 lingue,
tanti video, ma questa è una parte
in cui dobbiamo ancora migliorare tantissimo,
gli audiolibri, 3,5 milioni di tracce musicali,
significa alcune centinaia di migliaia di album musicali.
Ecco questi sono tutti contenuti
che l'utente prende a prestito
esclusivamente facendo login su una piattaforma
e accedendo ai contenuti che la sua biblioteca
ha acquisito per suo conto
secondo il modello tradizionale
della distribuzione dei contenuti nelle biblioteche pubbliche;
con modelli differenziati:
un ebook ad esempio, l'ultimo romanzo di Umberto Eco
viene preso a prestito, viene salvato dall'utente,
e rimane a disposizione per 14 giorni,
al termine del periodo il libro diventa disponibile
per un altro utente.
Ma per altri contenuti,
i modelli distributivi sono completamente differenti.
Eppure tutto questo non è sufficiente.
Questo è un progetto importante,
al quale credo moltissimo.
È un progetto imprenditoriale
che avrà ancora una larga diffusione.
Ma questo non è sufficiente.
Questa immagine, il fregio che vedete
è sul portale della Public Library di Boston:
"Free to all", libero o aperto per tutti.
C'è un punto sul quale siamo ancora a tempo, come paese,
a competere con i paesi più avanzati,
con gli Stati Uniti, con la Corea del Sud,
con altre realtà più avanzate della nostra.
Ed è il disegno
di una grande biblioteca nazionale, digitale italiana.
Perchè qui la domanda è:
è possibile conservare l'ideale ottocentesco
di un grande contenitore del totale
della cultura, accessibile per tutti?
Oppure quest'idea è inevitabilmente tramontata,
obsoleta per ragione tecnologiche, sociali, legali?
Si tratta di rispondere e di impegnarsi
su questa domanda.
Che cos'è tutto il contenuto?
Ecco questa è una cosa che in realtà si disegna
abbastanza semplicemente.
Tutto il contenuto vuol dire tutti i libri,
tutto il materiale filmato, tutta la musica.
Potete immaginarlo, grosso modo,
come un'area che ha le seguenti articolazioni:
da un lato c'è il materiale che è protetto da copyright,
pensate ai libri, ci sono i libri in commercio,
i libri fuori commercio e tra i libri fuori commercio,
c'è anche un sottoinsieme piccolissimo,
molto complesso da gestire,
che è costituito dalle cosiddette "opere orfane",
cioè quelle di cui sappiamo che esisterebbe
il detentore dei diritti, ma non riusciamo a trovarlo,
non sappiamo dov'è, non possiamo identificarlo.
Dall'altro lato c'è l'insieme di ciò che è
o protetto da copyright, eppure licenziato gratuitamente,
con delle licenze particolari.
Molti di voi avranno sentito parlare
delle licenze Creative Commons o di modelli simili,
oppure di opere nel pubblico dominio,
cioè opere per i quali i diritti di autore siano scaduti.
Questo modello, che qui ovviamente è iper-semplificato,
è un modello che si ripartisce uniformemente
attraverso tutte le tipologie multimediali.
Se volete costruire una grande biblioteca nazionale
bisogna che ci mettiate tutte queste cose.
Eppure, riuscire in un'impresa del genere
è estremamente complicato.
Negli Stati Uniti, Google ha iniziato
una super campagna di digitalizzazione
che ha prodotto ad oggi la digitalizzazione
di circa 15 milioni di volumi,
che ha incontrato degli ostacoli legali apparentemente insormontabili,
negli Stati Uniti e in altri paesi del mondo.
Stanno nascendo iniziative nuove:
queste due figure di cui ho messo la foto
in una delle mie ultime diapositive
sono di Robert Darnton, che è un grande storico
e anche il direttore della biblioteca universitaria di Harvard,
che sta promuovendo l'ideale
di una Digital Public Library of America,
una biblioteca digitale pubblica americana.
E quello che io trovo straordinario,
e che noi dovremmo cercare di riprodurre nel nostro paese,
è il fatto che questa è una biblioteca pubblica
non nel senso di una biblioteca dello Stato
e della Pubblica Amministrazione.
La parola "pubblico" negli Stati Uniti
assomiglia molto di più
a quello che è stato definito da Eleanor Hallstrom,
che ha vinto recentemente un Nobel per l'economia,
per la sua teoria dei Commons, dei beni comuni,
C'è un sistema di autoregolazione che è trasversale
rispetto alla distinzione tra privato e pubblico.
La costruzione di una biblioteca digitale nazionale
oggi implica relazioni e dinamiche di rapporto
tra il pubblico e il privato completamente nuove,
assolutamente inedite,
senza le quali questo compito sarà
assolutamente impossibile da realizzare.
Sono necessarie nuove norme, nuove licenze,
nuovi modelli contrattuali, un sistema di regole dinamico
che sia in grado di assorbire tutte le novità
che proverranno dall'evoluzione dell'editoria digitale.
E in sintesi, una vera e propria nuova economia della biblioteca.
Oggi i processi di digitalizzazione del materiale librario in Italia
sono davvero al lumicino.
Lo Stato italiano non investe un euro.
L'unico grande progetto è un progetto
realizzato dal Ministero dei Beni Culturali
in accordo con Google,
che digitalizzerà nei prossimi anni, pare, 1 milione di volumi
della nostra biblioteca nazionale centrale di Firenze.
Bene, quello che noi cercheremo di fare,
non da soli come impresa,
ma cercando un larghissimo spettro di collaborazioni,
è reagire a questo stato di fatto
e provare per una volta a reagire
senza chiedere l'aiuto dello Stato;
cioè provare a mettere assieme una pluralità di soggetti
che ovviamente dovranno includere
anche soggetti pubblici, ma non solo,
per riuscire a costruire un grande contenitore
che assomigli perlomeno e sia in grado di competere
nel servizio offerto agli utenti
a quanto si sta realizzando negli Stati Uniti e in altri paesi.
Il nostro progetto è partito senza fondi nel 2009
con pochissime adesioni,
che stanno aumentando rapidamente.
Io ho l'impressione che questo sia uno dei modi
attraverso cui un'idea così larga, così ambiziosa
può essere realizzata.
Cioè convincere con molta pazienza
un'enorme quantità di soggetti
del fatto che questo può essere realizzato,
che c'è un valore aggiunto fortissimo
nell'operazione.
Semplicemente, qui il destino in gioco,
la posta in gioco è la possibilità di riprodurre
un modello di trasferimento della nostra cultura
e anche la possibilità di rimanere,
dal punto di vita delle strutture di accesso alla conoscenza,
ad un ritardo ragionevole dai paesi più avanzati.
La mia impressione è che,
non solo chi ci governa, ma in generale
chi ha responsabilità nell'ambito dei contenuti,
non abbia una percezione chiara
della gravità di questo ritardo
e a questo bisogna reagire
non tanto con manifesti, non con iniziative politiche,
ma con azioni pragmatiche molto precise.
Grazie.
(Applausi)